so the house commission to investigate
the january 6 trump riots is going to
kick off tomorrow now as you might
remember this is not the the
um commission that was proposed uh
months ago which republicans rejected
this is the new one this is the one
where um kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader leader selected five
republicans
and nancy pelosi said jim banks and jim
jordan can't be on this
committee they're sort of part of the
problem they should be maybe witnesses
more than uh investigators and
ultimately republicans saying well then
we won't give you anyone but nancy
pelosi inviting republican liz cheney
uh and republican adam kinzinger to
participate that kicks off tomorrow
and maybe we will get some more answers
to some of the questions that remain
about exactly what happened on january
6th although the big picture of what
happened is pretty clear
we knew at the time and it was reported
at the time donald trump seemed to
really like what was going on
until there was this moment on january
6th
where donald trump was reportedly
watching and
the low-class nature as he saw it of his
protesters of the writers he felt was
making him look bad
that trump reportedly didn't like but
big picture trump seemed pretty pleased
with with what was going on
we now have new reporting from this book
i alone can fix it by washington post
reporters
carol lennog and philip rucker where
they
uh now are saying trump was quote almost
giddy
watching the capitol riot on tv
uh carol lennog co-author of i alone can
fix it
described the scene in an interview with
cnn
lennig said trump was reluctant to call
off the rioters despite urging from
daughter ivanka
that also relates to a story that we
recently covered
let's get right into the clip of carol
lenig
explaining it herself on cnn as the
attack on the capitals occurring
what is trump's state of mind what is
the feeling inside the white house
you know it's amazing because we
we all lived it we were in journalism
but we and america lived it through tv
and he is in his dining room off the way
off the oval office
watching it and almost giddy because i
mean he does watch a lot of tv
but here he is seeing thousands of his
supporters
basically trample up to the steps break
through barricades
all rallying for him to try to stop the
certification of the election for joe
biden
and he feels really supported and
emboldened by that
and again giddy keep in mind that when
these people
are regardless of their intention when
they
are storming the capital and going
through those barricades
they're committing a crime yeah of
course he was
of course he was this really shouldn't
be surprising
to anybody donald trump seemed to at
least
for some period of time on january 6th
believe
these people might actually overthrow
the election results
overthrow the government that is set to
be sworn in just two weeks later
and install me as president which would
basically be becoming a dictator right
he would have lost but somehow been
installed by force
this is why he resisted sending in the
national guard
to stop the riots despite being asked to
multiple times and we were
on a live stream many of us were
watching it together wondering okay
it's one o'clock it's two o'clock it's
three o'clock
does it really take this long to muster
national guard i mean we know
we have the biggest military and the
best everything and so
it's been two hours and in a situation
where clearly you need
uh people to show up to restore order
nobody's showing up
could it really just be taking this long
to get there from virginia or from
maryland or wherever the case they were
stationed
and the answer was of course not of
course not the reason that they didn't
show up
was because donald trump was resisting
sending them and
uh this this confirms everything that
was being reported at the time even if
you looked remember that first video
trump did i'm forgetting the exact
timeline but it might have been five
ish eastern time where trump came out
and said
it's time to go home we love you
paraphrasing here you're justified
in your belief about the election being
stolen the impetus for why you showed up
and rioted
the this is my paraphrasing is a good
one it's an
accurate one because it was really
stolen but as much as we love you
it's time to go home even in that you
could tell trump was thrilled and trump
was
was actually supportive of the rioters
and so
that further is corroboration and you
have to read the book to look at the
full the full sourcing of it
um that indeed is is more corroboration
of what we already believed to be true
and then lastly we reported a few weeks
ago that
ivanka trump and jared kushner are
supposedly distancing themselves from
donald trump pretty significantly
and carol lenig's additional insights in
the book along with
philip rucker are that ivanka trump was
asking donald trump as the riots were
unfolding
you've got to stop this do something
about this you've got to do something
about it and trump refused and
again if the reporting that we've seen
is to be believed
that indeed ivanka trump was not pleased
about that
that would also be coherent with what
has already been reported
none of this is shocking it's just none
of this we don't there's nothing that
we're hearing
here where we say whoa that's totally
out of character with trump
that just doesn't make any sense no the
impression we got at the time was that
it was because of trump that authorities
didn't show up more quickly
that's exactly the reporting that has
come out since the our impression at the
time from trump's
weird video was he liked the rioters and
that is now what philip rucker and carol
lennog are
uh asserting in their book i alone can
fix it so none of it is shocking but
there is more detail
in the book um the one other thing i
would say when
sometimes people write to me they say
david like what's the point of this book
now at this point
well books take time to write you know
to expect a book about the trump riots
on january 16th 10 days later it's not
it's not reasonable it takes a while to
write books and when you're when you're
writing a book
and sourcing it and fact checking it in
this type of thing it's going to take
some period of time
there were lots of people who weren't
really paying attention back then to
those reports
and they're now hearing this stuff for
the first time and i do think that
that's relevant as well i know trump
owns the republican party
most republicans just don't care about
this or they won't believe it
but i do think that we're exposing more
people to this
reality for the first time and that is
worth it but
just an incredible incredible revelation
and completely coherent
with what we believed at the time